All right, thank you.
All right, thank you. Good afternoon.
So among the excitement around
the accelerated development and the increased
accessibility of artificial intelligence
has really been this sense of optimism in our
industry for how AI can transform
manufacturing and supply chain operations.
But I'm commonly asked, uh, as
the industry just grapples with delivering on
that transformation,
what, what would be a clear framework for
how we balance modernization
with short-term financial ROI
while still building the foundations
for long-term, uh, innovative capabilities.
My name is Joe Rosing. I lead our center of excellence
for manufacturing and supply chain at AWS.
And in today's session, we're really gonna talk about,
uh, uh, the best practice approaches
for how we can modernize manufacturing and supply
chain operations to really accelerate
the benefit that we can be, uh, achieving
with artificial intelligence.
Now that optimism that I spoke on before is really
grounded in the sense that the,
the industry right now is ripe for
change and ripe for re-industrialization,
and a lot of that is because of some unique challenges
that our industry continues to face.
Uh, we're still, for example, continuously
trying to build supply chain resiliency.
We're managing the impact of
an aging workforce and demographics on
business continuity.
And we're also, you know, struggling with
risks or mitigating risks related to geopolitics
and trade.
But fundamentally, re-industrialization
really has to be AI driven,
because for us to build a competitive advantage
through manufacturing and supply chain operations,
it's all gonna come down to how quickly
we can perceive, react and
re-optimize based on these changing
conditions. And we're gonna have to do that at a
scale and speed that simply surpasses
human capabilities.
And so the winners in reindustrialization
are not going to be those that, you know, just
implement technology for technology's sake
or chase the latest models that got released.
The winners are going to be those that really focus
on where we're going to deliver a financial
ROI,
but also where we can deliver on
the durable needs of the operation
or of the supply chain.
And I put those durable needs into three buckets,
the first of which is reducing variation.
So how do we become predictably boring
at the key performance indicators that matter
most for our business?
But when it comes to AI it's really thinking about
that through the lens of how do we solve
problems with human-like reasoning,
but with machine scale consistency.
The second durable need really comes down to empowering
employees. And we've been talking about empowering
employees in our industry for decades.
It's lean manufacturing, Toyota
production system, common topics.
But it's never more important than now when we talk
about artificial intelligence,
because fundamentally the role of artificial intelligence
should be how we empower employees to make better
decisions faster and also how we use
the technology to reduce the cognitive
load on our employees and really
free them up to do higher order tasks.
And then the 3rd durable need is just how
we execute at speed
and are able to re-optimize capacity
against those changing conditions. And like
I mentioned before, be able to do that at a
scale and speed
that's going to surpass the way that we can do it
today through manual processes.
Now, many manufacturers
have started this journey, right? There, like I said,
there is a lot of interest, there's a lot of optimism
around the role that AI can play in helping us
achieve things like closed loop manufacturing systems,
helping us make real-time production adjustments
or software defined manufacturing,
and further reduce variation in our
processes.
But the fact of the matter is, only about a
third of the industry has their
data in a place that they really can innovate
at scale, and where they can quickly implement
a POC for example, of an AI use
case in one factory, and then replicate
that success across multiple factories.
And so really the role that AWS is playing.
Is helping us transition
from our traditional model of
how we'd manage data in the factories and the
operations to one that is gonna be really
defined for us to achieve software defined
manufacturing.
So if we think about this traditional ISA 95
Purdue pyramid model,
it fundamentally is not built
to support the demands and the requirements of
an AI world.
We have inherent data silos across each
of those layers,
and there's a lot of variation across each of those
layers when we look at the global manufacturing
footprint.
And so a lot of the work we're doing from a modernization
perspective
in the OT world in particular, is
thinking around how do we get to this desired future
state where we're running a lot of the IT
applications in the cloud, but we're thinking
about new characteristics
of what the factory looks like.
And we can define those characteristics by first
saying we're going to truly merge IT
and OT and make sure that it's integrated,
both as a function in terms of capabilities
of our teams, but also from a
technology perspective.
The second tenet is really making sure that we can
enable any to any communication.
So for example, when we think about agentic
workflows and how they might operate on the plant
floor, or if we want to do closed loop feedback
controls, it's going to require us to take
an insight that we might be generating off
of an IT system and drive
the action or automate that action back into
the hardware or the shop floor layer. And
that's going to really again require this any to any
communication capability.
And then the third piece is moving
beyond what we've traditionally thought of as systems
of record
and maybe systems of transaction,
to also now thinking about systems of action.
So a control tower type of view
or a way that we can observe
what the AI is doing and how it's
interacting with all of these systems.
And that will also then fundamentally change the
role that those systems of record and systems
of transaction, so the ERPs,
the MES, the skate systems, for example,
the role that those systems are going to play in the
operation. Now
as we do this again, I was, as I mentioned earlier,
I, I oftentimes get asked for what are some of the
best practice approaches or how do we, how
do we boil this down so we can think
comprehensively about a long term manufacturing
strategy that allows us to
drive modernization, but also get
our data in a place that we have the right foundations
for long term innovation and then start
thinking about where we implement AI in our
processes.
So really we think about this in 3 layers.
The top layer we call digitally composed
outcomes.
So it's thinking about how do we achieve those
common KPIs, uh, improving
maintenance reliability, improving quality
yields, improving on-time delivery in
full, for example.
How can we improve those KPIs through
technology? But what's different now from maybe
a couple of years ago when we think of the
industry 4.0 type of uh
movement.
Is we're not just talking about those
topics in the sense of
doing computer vision for defect detection
or doing predictive maintenance.
Instead we want to think holistically about the
process. How do I redefine the way
we do maintenance management?
How do I redefine the way we do quality
management?
Because now we have new tools at our disposal
to create future state process maps
that are way different than the traditional way
of doing these things.
So we're gonna have a look in a minute here of how we can integrate
AI into redefining those workflows.
The second layer we call our industrial data fabric.
And this is really where we talk about industrial
data ops and driving contextualization
of that OT data as close to the
source as possible, and building the knowledge
graph that really becomes required for
us to have this data foundation where
we can innovate off of that at scale.
And it's building common patterns such that
when we have success in one facility, this
is the layer that allows us to extend that
success or replicate it across multiple
facilities.
And then the last layer is thinking about manufacturing
application modernization
and doing that also in mind of what is
the role of OT security or how do
we maintain OT security as we
go do this modernization
and actually achieve a higher security posture
than we might have today.
And so this is where we're commonly working with customers
now about looking at those traditional
applications like Escada, a historian,
an MES system. And how do we deploy
those on a modern hybrid-based architecture
where we're still meeting the latency and the security
requirements at the edge,
but we're achieving the cost efficiency
and the DevOps capabilities of the cloud.
Uh, and so 11 way to kind of then
take this one step further.
It's just to further simplify it, of those
three layers.
The top layer we want to talk about creating a
common user interface for integrated
workflows.
The reason this becomes important is
because today,
a lot of operators are interacting with multiple
systems. Think about the time it takes
for an operator to come up to speed on their job,
if they have to interact with an MES, an EAM,
a CMS, an ERP, all
these different applications on the shop floor.
But now with the ability of implementing AI
into these workflows, we can actually create
a common layer, a common user interface
that greatly simplifies how we
execute operations, and it
removes some of that cognitive load off of our
employees.
The second layer when we talk that industrial data
fabric, really what we want to achieve here is
building new business capabilities and
data products that allow us to,
once we have that data product, have
repeatability up the stack in terms of
the analytics
or the models that we build off of that data.
And then on the bottom layer, we talk modernize,
it's really developing a repeatable
process around how we assess
requirements of those applications,
how we mobilize the teams around
capability gaps that we might have in today's
environment, and then modernize the
application on a hybrid architecture.
To address those capability gaps, and
we might do that application by
application, but allows us to develop a
repeatable process where we can accelerate
uh that whole transition and really build out
a long term roadmap for modernizing
those applications across our global manufacturing
footprint.
Now I wanna dive a little bit deeper into building
that common user interface for integrated
workflows,
because what's different now, as I mentioned
before, is our ability to pull new tools out of
the toolbox to redefine
how we do work and how work gets done on the
shop floor.
Uh, and as you read the quote, what's important
to think about is not just plugging AI
into the existing workflow.
Uh, that's, that's just a short term view
of how we might get a POC done,
but really doesn't help us
build lasting change and build
lasting competitive advantage throughout,
through the way we execute manufacturing and supply
chain operations.
So what we wanna do instead.
Is take kind of a traditional approach of
systems engineering, but look at the new AI
tools and think about this in
a way of AI systems engineering.
And we don't wanna look at these tools of automation
and assistance or or chatbots
and agents as a progression,
right? This is not something where we start at automation,
and we've set a goal that we're gonna have every
workflow be fully autonomous multi-agentic
systems.
These are in fact
different tools in the toolbox
that we're gonna pull out and use most cost
efficiently at the task level
for us to have an overall systems
engineering approach for how we are gonna
rearchitect the workflows or the
processes on the shop floor.
As we go about doing that, there's a couple of tenants
that we wanna keep in mind.
The first is we simply don't wanna automate
the existing process.
Uh, there was a, a senior operations leader I
was speaking with about a month ago
who said, look, the reason why we're looking at this
process is it's broken today and it's
chaotic, and the worst thing I could do
right now is automate chaos.
So what we really wanna do is, let's, let's
map out the current state workflow or the current
state process,
but we want to start with a blank sheet of paper
and build that future, that desired future
state process map,
and then think through there what is the right tool.
And that brings us to the second point, which is
no tool rules them all.
So as much as we've been talking about agentic AI
this week,
agents are not the hammer for every nail,
OK? They are not going to be the most cost efficient
way to do every application.
Uh, it's also gonna be that we don't
necessarily need to get to lights out and fully autonomous
on every task.
But again, we're gonna think very strategically
about what's the right tool for the job.
And then lastly, we want to establish a new baseline
for continuous improvement.
So when I meet with customers,
many have a very strong culture of continuous
improvement, and they've done great work through Kaiser events,
and we don't want to lose that.
But we still want to make a leapfrog jump
in our capabilities and create a new
baseline from which we can drive continuous
improvement off of. And so that's uh
really kind of this, the starting point
now or this checkpoint that we have of
redefining workflows with this AI
systems engineering approach.
And we think about the framework now of, OK, well,
what tool do I use when?
We can map that out against a 2x2 matrix
of complexity and risk.
So when I build out my desired future state
workflow, I'm gonna identify all of
the tasks in that workflow.
And then I might say, OK, for a given tasks
that are lower risk and lower complexity,
those are ones that are going to be most cost efficient
for us to automate.
These are typically deterministic workflows.
They're rules-based. We can write if
then statements.
Again, the most cost-efficient way is going to be automating
those tasks.
The second box we might look at are tasks
that are going to continue to be done by the human.
So a simple example, this might be actually
doing the maintenance on the machine.
A human is still gonna have to turn the wrench, if
you will, on the machine, because an agent won't be able
to do that.
But I want to accomplish that task
at lower variation,
and I want to empower the employee to
accomplish that task at a high performance
or according to best practice principles.
And so this is where I'm not necessarily gonna have a chatbot,
but I'm gonna mature that chatbot into a formal
AI assistant.
And what I want that AI assistant to do is
provide troubleshooting guidance so I can
perform that task at lower variation
and again at best practice performance.
And then the role that agents come in is
really twofold.
So where I have a lower risk profile
on the task is where I'm gonna delegate
that task to the agent.
I've achieved a high enough confidence interval
in the output of the, of the model
or the output of what the agent is going to go do,
that I'm just going to delegate the agent to go do that
task
because it now removes it, uh, uh, as
something that I need to have a human do, and it
reduces that cognitive load on the employee.
If it's a higher pro a higher risk profile
task, I'm gonna still probably do it
through an agent or a predictive model, but
I'm gonna put a human in the loop.
And that's OK.
Again, we don't need to bring everything
to be a fully autonomous system.
But if it's higher risk, we want a human in the loop
to check the recommendation that's being
made by the predictive model,
or check what the agent wants to go do
before we give it the green light to go do that activity,
right? So this is just a simple
framework that helps us to think about, again,
we have these new tools in our toolbox.
How do we do this AI systems engineering where we
pick the right tool for the job based on
the risk profile of the task or the
complexity of the task,
such that now we have a redefined workflow
that appropriately integrates AI
into the way we get work done.
Now the last uh slide that I would end with,
it's just a little bit of a challenge,
that the speed at which we can accomplish this
transformation really comes down to a
leadership decision.
So the speed at which we can encourage our
teams to drive continuous improvement through
AI systems engineering, the speed
at which we can build competitive advantage
through integrating technology into our
manufacturing and supply chain processes,
the speed at which we can further use
technology to reduce variation, empower
employees, and re-optimize our
operations comes down to a leadership
decision and comes down to a decision
of really driving our teams to dive in
and start transforming.
And that's really my last point of encouragement
is the best place to start is to just
get started.
Let's pick a workflow that we can really dive
into that's begging for improvement.
Let's identify the KPI that we want
to improve as a result of that workflow
and really work backwards into what are the
data, what's the data requirement to
improve that KPI.
Uh, and then from there we can look at, OK,
what is the data strategy and the modernization
plan that we want to build so that we can
comprehensively go improve that
workflow across your manufacturing footprint.
And so with that, I wanna thank you for your time today.
Uh, if you have any questions, I'll be off to the side,
uh, after this session here. But thank you
for joining us at Reinvent, and I hope you have a great
rest of the afternoon.